so Leute ich sag's wie es ist keine
Begrüßung
keiner weiß wie lange der Rums hier noch
gut geht ich habe seit drei Tagen nicht
mehr geduscht hier im Raum sind 17 Grad
und wenn der Brown out das Stromnetz
zerlegt ist meine youtube-karriere auch
vorbei und selbst das sind nur die
kleinsten Symptome der multiplenkrisen
die uns gerade aus allen
Himmelsrichtungen den Arsch versohlen
Corona ist nach wie vor nicht vorbei ich
sag nur China die Klimakrise fängt
gerade erst an die Strom und Heizkosten
explodieren der Krieg in der Ukraine
geht bald in sein zweites Jahr die
Inflation in Deutschland lag im
vergangenen Jahr auf dem höchsten Stand
seit 70 Jahren etwa jede sechste
Deutsche ist von Armut betroffen das ist
der höchste gemessene Wert seit der
Wiedervereinigung
um es zusammenzufassen uns ging es noch
nie nie so schlecht wie heute
jetzt kommst du aber mal runter
[Musik]
schlimmste Zeit die ich je erlebt habe
also dass ich nicht lache wirklich diese
Weichei scheiße das kommt davon wenn man
nicht zweimal am Tag Fleisch ist
also wie hier 73
wir hatten genau die gleichen Probleme
ja also Ölkrise schon mal gehört da
drosseln arabische Ölstaaten ihre
Förderung und verhängen ein Embargo
gegen Staaten die gut mit Israel können
[Musik]
Ölpreis viermal so hoch kommt euch
bekannt vor klar es ist exakt die
gleiche Scheiße wie das bisschen
weltliches geruckelt über das Madame
waldkni sich im Jahr 2023 die Augen
ausheult
und streng genommen war sogar noch
schlimmer bei uns eigentlich ja wir
hatten Inflation aber im Gegensatz zu
euch Yogamatten Opfern hatten wir noch
rasant steigende Arbeitslosigkeit
Insolvenzen und wir durften am Sonntag
nicht mehr Auto fahren und es gab eine
zeitlich befristetes tempole mit von 100
auf deutschen Autobahn ist unfassbar
aber hatte einer geweint von uns nee
dann haben wir halt stattdessen
das ganze Jahrzehnt das war super gut
und zwischendurch haben wir noch rasant
tip top Alternativen zum Arabischen Öl
ausgebaut Ölplattform und Kernkraftwerk
super das funktioniert ja deshalb denkt
ihr bei den 70ern heute nicht an
Depressionen kalte Küche sondern an
rocken keine Hose
danke schön
so tschuldigung
kann jetzt die Uhr Oma vielleicht auch
noch mal ganz kurz
[Musik]
wir in den 20ern
uns ging es nämlich auch beschissen wir
hatten nicht einfach Inflation werden
über Inflation
[Musik]
eure
fünf sechs sieben Prozent da hätten wir
uns einen kleinen Finger für
abgeschnitten und das war hier eine noch
dümmere Idee als bei euch weil wir noch
keine Antibiotika hatten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schon Anfang Januar 1923 lag die
Inflation bei 7.400%
7.400 und das war nur der Anfang wir
hatten gerade den Ersten Weltkrieg
hinter uns
etwa so erfolgreich wie jetzt eure
Fußballnationalmannschaft bei der
letzten WM
und dann marschieren Frankreich und
Belgien ein und besetzen das Ruhrgebiet
unser Ruhrgebiet
[Musik]
weil wir mit den Reparationszahlungen
für den Ersten Weltkrieg ein bisschen
später dran war
[Musik]
das nenne ich mal ein ordentliches
Inkasso
[Musik]
gut und um die Folgen dieser Besatzung
zu überbrücken haben wir dann
ein bisschen Geld gedruckt
bisschen viel Geld
[Musik]
kann mir jemand eine Milliarde in Münzen
leihen für den Kaffeeautomaten
[Musik]
ich wollte noch was sagen noch mal zwei
Gründe warum es bei uns früher
beschissener war als bei euch ja 1923
ging es nur um Kohle hier bei uns nur um
Öl fossile Energie fanden wir richtig
sexy also bei euch ist sicherlich nicht
alles super vor allem nicht deine
weinerliche Einstellung Fräulein
aber ihr in der Zukunft ja wenigstens
schon mal angefangen mit der
Energiewende sogar das Aus für den
Verbrennermotor habt ihr beschlossen was
seid ihr verrückt geworden den guten
Verbrennermotor
okay meine Güte keine Ahnung dann war
halt früher nicht alles besser aber also
ich meine unabhängig von meiner neuen
Bambus Zahnbürste mit der ich jetzt das
Klima rette ist bei uns ja wirklich die
Demokratie in Gefahr die Ungleichheit
wächst und mit ihr auch das Misstrauen
in die Demokratie bei deutschen
Landtagswahlen gehen mittlerweile nur
noch 60% der Menschen wählen bei
Kommunalwahlen noch weniger wenn die
nicht Wähler eine Partei werden die
würden immer gewinnen und wenn heute
Bundestagswahl wäre dann würde die AFD
Umfragen zufolge bei 15% landen bei der
letzten Wahl lag sie noch bei 10 in
anderen Ländern sind die
Rechtspopulisten sogar schon längst an
der Regierung oder gefährlich nah dran
USA Türkei Italien Ungarn selbst in
Schweden dabei haben die in Schweden
doch eigentlich alles was man braucht so
zum Glück nicht hübsche Möbel kleine
Fleischbällchen und
diese super praktischen bunten Plastik
Clips mit denen man Chips in Tüten vom
weich werden beschützt und klar ein
bisschen habe ich auch das Gefühl dass
diese ganze starke Mann scheiße
eigentlich und Zeichen von Schwäche ist
ja Putin Orban Trump wir merken einfach
dass ihre Zeit vorbei ist
die sitzen frustriert zu Hause kriegen
keinen mehr hoch und kompensieren das
mit Hass und Atomwaffen das Problem ist
natürlich es sind echte Hass und echte
Atomwaffen also
jeder hämische putin-pimmel wird von mir
ist also potentiell Welt beendend ja
okay ja
bei uns in den 20ern
haben wir auch ein bisschen Erfahrung
mit frustrierten Männern mit
Allmachtsfantasien und
ohne jetzt die Stimmung komplett
ruinieren zu wollen da müsst ihr schon
aufpassen weil bei uns die 20er das
fängt eigentlich super an echte
Demokratie
Frauenwahlrecht kein Kaiser mehr super
Sexpartys in Berlin
aber dann kam die Wirtschaftskrise und
ein paar wichtige Leute haben richtig
schlechte Entscheidungen
deshalb brach die Industrieproduktion um
beinahe die Hälfte ein die
Arbeitslosenquote schoss auf
30%. kein Wunder also dass die Menschen
sauer waren und die Lösung für Ihre
Probleme bei Leuten mit einfachen
Antworten gesucht haben schon am 8
November 1923 läuft ein gewisser Adolf
Hitler in den Münchner Bürgerbräukeller
schießt mit seiner Pistole in die Decke
und ruft zum Putsch auf der ging damals
noch schief aber
ich habe also jede Menge Grund zur Panik
und für kurzkettige Kohlenhydrate
weil nämlich alles immer wieder
beschissen wird
andererseits und das sage ich jetzt nur
noch mal weil es wirklich nicht
offensichtlich ist also überhaupt nicht
wirklich gar nicht
[Musik]
dass ihr ja schon auch ein bisschen dazu
gelernt habt dann dazu kommt oder also
aber wie gesagt man sieht es praktisch
kaum ja gut stimmt also ihr seid totale
klimaschweine gewesen und ich ja ich
habe die Bambus Zahnbürste jetzt und
Ökostrom nee im Tesla
glaube ich wisst ihr was interessant ist
obwohl ich mich im Vergleich zu euch
krass weiterentwickelt habe modisch
emotional ja und wie gesagt die
Zahnbürste ich spare CO2 tonnenweise
aber was ich überhaupt nicht verändert
hat weder in den letzten 50 noch in 100
Jahren ist unser Wirtschaftssystem hier
Kapitalismus immer mehr mehr mehr mehr
mehr und das so billig wie möglich egal
wie sehr die Menschheit oder das Klima
darunter leidet komm das eventuell sein
dass da die zunehmende Ungleichheit
herkommt
hallo
hallo hier unten ja ich bin die Neue die
alte die neue alte
ich sitze hier im Jahre 1952 und zum
Thema Ungleichheit da kann ich ein paar
Sachen sagen bei uns ist der zweite
Weltkrieg noch gar nicht so lange her
den die dullis aus den 20ern uns
eingebrockt haben weil sie das mit den
Nazis nicht hingekriegt haben
ja und bei uns gab es als wir die
Bundesrepublik gegründet haben
tatsächlich ein Bewusstsein dafür dass
Demokratie und Gesellschaft nur
funktionieren wenn wir diesmal darauf
achten dass der Wohlstand gerecht
verteilt wird das oberste eine Prozent
der Bevölkerung besaß nämlich sechs
Jahre nach dem Krieg sagte 25% des
gesamten deutschen Vermögens und weil
wir wussten dass das nicht gerecht ist
weil sehr viele Menschen nach dem Krieg
mit gar nichts da standen gab es das
Gesetz über den Lastenausgleich
50 Prozent Sondersteuer auf das gesamte
Vermögen von Superreichen aber keine
Panik zahlbar über 30 Jahre also jedes
Jahr nur 1,67 Prozent damit die Reichen
ihren Hummer nicht kalt essen müssen und
wissen Sie was das hat ausgesprochen gut
funktioniert die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland war jahrzehntelang eines der
am wenigsten ungleichen Länder in dem
man leben konnte das ist ihnen in den
20er Jahren nicht gelungen und sie aus
den 70ern und den 80ern spätestens haben
es wieder verspielt also jetzt einfach
mal ein bisschen in die Hände spucken
und optimistisch nach vorne denken weil
es ist ja nicht so dass es keine
Lösungen oder Ideen gäbe ja also um den
Laden nicht wieder vor die Wand zu
fahren mit Schreiben erstens höhere
Erbschaftssteuer zweitens eine
Vermögenssteuer drittens eine
übergewinnsteuer viertens weniger
Steuerschlupflöcher für internationale
Großkonzerne nee Stopp Stopp Stopp Stopp
jetzt warte mal du das sind sehr viele
sehr komplizierte Wörter hast du das
nicht als kurzes PowerPoint oder hier
emojis hast du oder kannst schick mir
doch eine Mail was
wie melde ich eine Demo an jetzt deine
App
hallo ich spreche zu euch aus dem Jahr
30 23 es ist wichtig dass ihr den Kanal
abonniert um die Welt zu retten ihr seid
unsere einzige Chance